stafford aven district council is
currently consulting on a site
allocations plan
following on from the video about sua2
and sua4
there are four new site specific
proposals in and on the edges stratfor
upon avon which have been put forward
this video goes into a little bit of
detail about each one
proposal sua 5 lies east of shipston
road
the site comprises three hectares of
land immediately south of the roseburg
retail park
it has been identified to provide a
suitable opportunity for specific
businesses
currently operating on wharf road in the
town to relocate
this in turn will allow that part of the
canal quarter regeneration zone to be
redeveloped
and therefore help to deliver a key
component of the core strategy
as the site isn't identified in the
course strategy and is greenfield in
nature
it is necessary for the site allocations
plan to establish the principle of such
a development
the site is reasonably well related to
the physical form of the town
given its proximity to the retail park
and the two recent developments
comprising older people's accommodation
it will be necessary to ensure that the
immunity of adjacent residential
properties is not unduly affected
by the proposed business development
a legal agreement will be required to
ensure the occupation of the site is
restricted to specific named companies
relocated from the canal quarter
the exception to this is the scope for
small business units to be provided
there is a close relationship between
the canal quarter this site and reserve
housing site
str b identified in the plan the
district council
accepts that scrb may need to act as
enabling development
as such any viability issues will need
to be independently assessed to justify
the release of strb for this purpose
then we've got proposal s2a6
stratford-upon-avon gateway
this area incorporates henley street
windsor street arden street and green
hill street
in the centre of the town while it is
expected that most of the existing
uses will remain the proposal provides
for the redevelopment of specific parts
of the area for a range of appropriate
uses
these include visitor attractions and
accommodation
retail and other commercial uses offices
leisure
community and residential
the rejuvenation of the area will need
to comprise high quality buildings and
public realm
the historic fabric of the conservation
area is listed buildings
will need to be protected and enhanced
it would also provide scope for
additional walking routes through the
area
such as between arden street and windsor
street
there is an opportunity to create a
specific gateway feature on the approach
to the historic core of the town
possibly at the junction of birmingham
road and arden street
similarly there is scope for green hill
street to provide a more attractive
route into the town centre from the
railway station
it is intended that some sort of concept
plan will be produced
to guide the future enhancement of the
whole area
proposal scua 7 frother street slash
grove road
this is another part of the central area
of the town that is need in need of
rejuvenation
again it is stressed that there is no
exception that existing uses should be
redeveloped
however there are opportunities for new
uses to be provided
and as the recent hotels division shows
a range of commercial community and
residential would be appropriate
there may be scope to redevelop all or
parts of the public
car park in conjunction with
stratford-upon-avon town council
it will be necessary to retain listed
buildings and those of
local historical significance
proposal sua 8 stafford upon avon
college
the capacity of stratford-upon-avon
secondary school on ulster road is now
very limited
and there is no scope to provide
additional accommodation
on its existing site an opportunity has
arisen for the school to utilize
adjacent land owned by stratfor college
this is currently used as a car park but
is now supplies to requirements
war russia county council has now
acquired this land for the school to use
it is understood it will remain as a car
park but this will
release land within the school campus
for additional buildings
in any case the land is prone to
flooding which is a major constraint for
development
i hope this has helped explain these
four sites remember you can find out
more in the site allocations plan
and submit any comments you have by
visiting our website at
www.stratford.gov dot uk
forward slash zappo